herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute live
corona massentests in österreich nach
der slowakei nach südtirol haben jetzt
auch drei bundesländer bei unseren
nachbarn in österreich mit corona
massentests begonnen
in wien in vorarlberg und in tirol
können sich sonnen sich millionen von
österreicher freiwillig auf das virus
testen lassen wie hier in wien in der
bundeshauptstadt in österreich gibt es
zwei große hallen sowie das messezentrum
wo sich bis zu 150000 menschen pro tag
testen lassen sollen können wir werden
die positiven heraus finden auch wenn
sie keine symptome haben so
zuversichtlich der österreichische
gesundheitsminister bei uns in
deutschland keine massentest aber neu
seit heute können sich an schulen und
kitas lehrer und betreuer selbstständig
nach einer schulung auf corona testen
kritik kommt von einigen ärzteverbänden
sie warnen vor dem risiko dass die
schnelltests vielleicht nicht richtig
ablaufen dass fehler gemacht werden und
das dann bei einem falschen negativen
resultat man sich in trügerischer
sicherheit wähnt und das ganze sozusagen
zu einem super spreading führen könnte
kritik dort manche lehrer die ratlos
sind was muss ich vivo tun viele fragen
also wir wollen sie klären was ist von
den massen test zu halten und wie
zuverlässig sind diese corona test
überhaupt wir reden mit einer frau die
sich mit den texten bestens auskennt uns
alle fragen wohl beantworten kann mit
frau professor bettina löffler am
uniklinikum in jena vielen dank dass sie
zeit haben herzlich willkommen danke
herr rieger jahren ab sie direkt die
frage wir haben gesehen eben in
österreich chor oder massentest was
halten sie davon
diese massen testungen die geben ihnen
eine momentaufnahme desinfektions
geschehens also die dienen natürlich
dazu hochinfektiöse patienten oder
kandidaten heraus zu fischen und unter
quarantäne zu stellen
dass sie eben die infektionen nicht
weiter tragen aber man muss bedenken die
massen testungen liefern nur eine
momentaufnahme des geschehens das kann
an den folgenden tagen schon wieder ganz
anders aussehen und die massen testungen
mit diesen antigen schnell testen sind
nicht so sensitiv wie die pcr also sie
werden nicht alle infizierten leute
damit die diktieren
das muss man sich bewusst machen ja es
ist ja ein bisschen liegt ja auf der
hand banfield so zu den nachbarn wie
gesagt österreich die slowakei die
südtiroler haben das auch schon gemacht
und da schwingt ja so ein bisschen die
hoffnung mit dass man dann klarheit
bekommt aber es gibt eben diese
massentest nicht in deutschland wäre das
nicht auch irgendwas für uns ich denke
deutschland ist auch zu groß um um
massen testungen bei uns durchführen zu
können so viele test systeme können wir
gar nicht auftreiben
das ist schon mal ein wichtiger aspekt
aber ich denke auch nicht dass ist bei
uns unbedingt sinnvoll wäre
wir haben in vielen regionen des
infektionsgeschehen schon noch unter
gewisser kontrolle können auch
infektionsketten zuverlässig oder
zielgerichtet nachverfolgen
das ist sicher eine bessere strategie
als so eine doch relativ teure massen
testung zu initiieren
also sie würden sagen es ist ja so die
politik der gesundheitsminister das rkw
sagen es ist besser gezielt zu testen da
wo die infektionen sind als in der
fläche und selbst der vorstand der
deutschen stiftung patientenschutz herr
eugen brief sagt heute massentest sind
strohfeuer halten sie also diese
massentest wie wir sie jetzt in
österreich sehen auch für ein bisschen
politischen aktionismus ja gut mit dem
strohfeuer das ist eben dass man nur
eine momentaufnahme bekommt wie das
infektionsgeschehen jetzt gerade an
diesem tag eben stattfindet und wie
gesagt man kriegt eben nur
hochinfektiöse patienten rausgefiltert
das mag schon einen gewissen sinn machen
weil diese patienten
können natürlich viele weitere anstecken
aber was die gefahr eben dabei ist dass
man sich in einer falschen sicherheit
wiegt also die leute die negativ
getestet wurden dürfen auf keinen fall
alle hygiene regeln missachten und
denken na ja jetzt bin ich ja frei
getestet jetzt kann ich meine maske
weglassen dass es sicher nicht sinnvoll
weil wir wissen diese antigene schnell
test ist in mich so sensitiv nicht so
empfindlich und menschen mit einer
niedrigeren virus last im
nasen-rachen-raum werden sie damit nicht
zuverlässig rausgefiltert bekommen
damit haben sie indirekt schon ein
bisschen eine frage beantwortet die über
youtube detektive hier stellt können wir
wieder verein sport starten mit den
schnelltest es ist echt schlimm für
kinder
wenn ihnen monatelang der vereinssport
fehlt also vielleicht ein trainer der
ein bisschen sozusagen traurig ist dass
er die kinder nicht trainieren kann das
also die kinder keinen sport machen
können aber wenn ich sie sozusagen
richtig verstehe dann sind die
schnelltests ja auch nicht unbedingt die
hoffnung dass man schnell wieder verein
sport machen kann
schauen wir aber uns erst mal genau an
wie diese antigene schnelltests
funktionieren und besprechen dann einige
fragen die wir hier auch noch an
bei anti gen tests wird nicht aufwändig
nach dem erbgut der viren gesucht
sondern nach molekülen die
charakteristisch für die viren sind
ähnlich wie bei einem
schwangerschaftstest das ergebnis auf
einem teststreifen angezeigt und liegt
nach etwa 15 bis 30 minuten vor
damit ist der anti gen test deutlich
schneller als der sonst übliche pcr test
aber auch weniger zuverlässig in den
letzten wochen ist die zahl der
hersteller von anti gen tests explodiert
es gibt mehr als 200 produkte allerdings
mit großen qualitätsunterschiede sagen
experten
anti gen tests bieten laut
bundesregierung die möglichkeit mehr zu
testen und schneller infektionen zu
erkennen deswegen eignet sie sich
besonders für besucher beschäftigte und
patienten von pflegeheimen und
krankenhäusern
tja verläuft sie kennen sich bestens aus
mit diesem antigen schnell das können
sie noch mal ganz genau erklären wie er
in der reihenfolge funktioniert das soll
er eben schnell gehen und wie geht das
ja genau also man muss nach wie vor mit
einem stäbchen so einen stäbchen dass
man eben in die nasen rachenraum
einführen kann ein nasen rachenabstrich
entnehmen wenn dann muss diese stäbchen
in einer profi lösung ein getunkt werden
ausgewaschen werden und diese puffer
lösung muss man nach diesem auswaschen
des städtchens auf diesen antigen
schnelltest drauf tropfen da gibt es ein
gewisses feld und hier muss eben die
probe drauf getropft werden
und dann wartet man so ungefähr zehn
minuten ist die flüssigkeit sich hier
entlang gezogen hat über diese zwei
streifen und an eine streifen kann man
erkennen ob eben der test funktioniert
hat von den prinzipien und am zweiten
streifen kann man dann ablesen ob der
test positiv wird das klingt ja erstmal
ganz einfach vorläufer aber jens eppler
fragt ich stelle mir auch die frage kann
man denn lernen wie man die probe sicher
entnimmt und über youtube schickt stefan
friede auch so ein bisschen seine
skeptische meinung er sagt
wahrscheinlich ist der test als solcher
sehr genau aber der abstrich
beziehungsweise die korrekte
probenentnahme
und vorbereitung ist sicher ein großer
anteil eines fehlers wie sieht es so aus
es ist genau korrekt das ist eine sehr
gute frage und das ist genau auf unsere
angst gerade wenn das personen
durchführen sollen die nicht so geschult
sind die korrekte entnahme des nasen
rachen abstrich es ist ja nicht so
einfach man muss wirklich hinten im bund
an die rachen band gelangen und genauso
durch die nase an die rache und wand bis
zur rachen wand nur dann ist der
abstrich korrekt durchgeführt und das
ist natürlich wenn man das an sich
selbst entnehmen müsste oder jemand
nicht geschult ist doch nicht so einfach
durchzuführen
also ich meine wenn man ja sonst hört
schnelltests antigen schnelltest da hab
ich als bisher gedacht wenn ich klasse
dann kann ich in die apotheke gehen
zahlen ein bisschen was holen wir den
test macht das zuhause ja und dann bin
ich auf der sicheren seite wenn ich
vielleicht an weihnachten meine eltern
besuchen will also so einfach ist es
nicht
ich denke wenn man so einen abstrich an
sich selber durchführt es ist sicher
keine gute situation weil sie wissen
hier selber wenn sie sich so ein
stäbchen hier so ein langes stäbchen bis
in den rachen schieben da gibt's
schutzreflexe das ist nicht sehr
angenehm und es sollte schon jemand
machen der weiß wie so was gemacht wird
und es eben auch korrekt durchführen
kann
jetzt kommt schon die sozusagen
detailfrage von rosi braunert über
facebook warum muss man denn tief in der
nase nach corona viren suchen warum so
tief in den rachen nase warum das alles
weil sich die korona viren in einem nach
der inkubationszeit vor allem in dem
rachen vermehrt werden also die dringen
in die rachenschleimhaut zellen ein und
werden dort zuerst mal repliziert und
das ist der ort wo man eben eine hohe
virus konzentration auch vermutet in der
frühphase von der erkrankung und die
möchte man auch bekommen
also es reicht nicht wenn man sich mit
so einem stäbchen nur an der backe
entlang streicht es kann ebenfalls
negativ sein
also haben wir auch schon mal verstanden
es ist halt nicht so einfach wie sagen
wir mal so eine speichelprobe die ist ja
vielleicht nicht so deshalb sagen ja
gemacht haben es ist relativ unangenehm
weil es eben ziemlich weit rein durch
nase zum rachen raum geht bedeutet ein
positiver test dass jemand dass die
person dann wirklich infiziert ist ist
das glasklar fragt über youtube ricky
marco also die antigen schnell testen
da ist es nicht so ganz klar
empfohlen wird generell das ist auch in
österreich so dass wenn diese
testsysteme in erster linie positiv
waren man sofort einen weiteren abstrich
entnehmen sollte und noch als zusätzlich
ein pcr test durchführen sollte um das
ergebnis einfach zu bestätigen also das
heißt in österreich ist es so die massen
testet jetzt mit diesen anti gehen
schnell fest und wenn der bei jemandem
positiv ist dann sagt man nicht du bist
positiv geht es in quarantäne sondern
weil ich sie richtig verstehe dann wird
sozusagen dann der pcr test gemacht
korrekt jetzt steht sie jetzt haben sie
ja schon irgendwie wunderbar gezeigt
dann sieht man das ergebnis man könnte
ja mein auch das ist ja lieber ein
schwangerschaftstest man liest das
einfach ab aber die user schreiben ja
auch ist das so einfach dann auch zu
erkennen ob es positiv oder negativ ist
ist das also wirklich so einfach wie bei
einem schwangerschaftstest
ja das ist so der nächste schritt also
wo es auch zu fehlern kommen kann
wir haben bei uns im labor auch einige
dieser schnell test systeme ausprobiert
und haben durchaus bei manchen
abstrichen von corona patienten nicht
ein eindeutiges signal detektieren
können sondern es gibt auch situationen
wo es so ein ein teststreifen nur leicht
positiv wird also wohl nur ein ganz
leichter streifen sichtbar wird und das
ist natürlich für den laien sehr schwer
zu beurteilen ist das jetzt ein
positives ergebnis oder ist es eher ein
negativer wir können das mal am
praktischen beispiel machen sie waren so
nett und haben uns ein bild zugeschickt
das müssen wir jetzt einfach mal
vorlegen und zwar von drei beispielen
links sehen wir also negativ so sieht
ein negativ test klipp und klar aus
rechts positiv zwei balken aber ich
glaube das problem beschreiben sie ihr
selbst roller schlaf ist das in der
mitte
das sind der mitte das sehen sie der
untere balken die er ist sehr sehr
schwach positiv wird quasi so leicht
reparieren einen streifen zu sehen
aber das ist ein positives signal also
in unserem fall ist dieses eine testung
von corona patienten wo wir wussten die
haben die wir noch im nasen-rachen-raum
aber eben in geringerer konzentration
und das ist natürlich schwierig in der
ablesung ja und dann verstehe ich
sozusagen richtig die bedenken der
ärzteverbände die sagen wenn dann jemand
einen schnelltest macht sagt oh ich bin
ja negativ jetzt nehmen wir das mittlere
bild was wir eben gesehen haben und es
ist aber tatsächlich positiv also ein
falsch negatives und erwägt sich in
sicherheit geht raus begrüßt leute und
lässt die maske fallen und alle
vorsichtsmaßnahmen dann könnte das
natürlich genau das gegenteil bewirken
keine sicherheit sondern im gegenteil
eine riesige gefahr für alle richtig das
ist ganz korrekt und deswegen bei uns im
krankenhaus für das patientenmanagement
nutzen wir diese schnell testsysteme gar
nicht weil uns ein fall auch passiert
ist dass eine patientin bei uns in über
die notaufnahme ins krankenhaus kam in
den akten stand eben der satz sie wurde
schon getestet und wäre negativ auf
corona aber das war eben durch einen
schnelltest erfolgt und sie kamen auch
ohne maske musste dann in der folge
einer anderen erkrankung intubiert
werden also sprich viele leute waren an
dieser patientin dran und hinterher
stellte sich dann heraus sie war doch
corona positiv und das ist natürlich
eine situation die man im krankenhaus
vermeiden möchte weil dann viele
kontaktpersonen entstanden sind die dann
durch gesundheitsamt überwacht werden
mussten
das deckt sich eben auch mit dem was der
ärzteverband der verbund bund heute
gesagt hat man sieht dort nämlich die
gefahr dass selbst selbsttests die
momentan lebenswichtigen kontakt
beschränkungen begrenzungen unterlaufen
könnten weil menschen dann mit einem
negativen test wo sie glauben wir dass
negative aber ist es nicht sich dann
nicht mehr an die regeln
gebunden fühlen und sie der verbund sagt
eben die maxime lautet doch weiterhin
kontakte begrenzen kontakte begrenzen
kontakte begrenzen
eine andere frage im beitrag haben wir
es ja gehört es gibt 200 produkte dieses
antigen schnelltests sind die denn alle
gleichwertig oder ist es tatsächlich so
dass man gar nicht so sicher ist der
eine funktioniert vielleicht gut bei dem
anderen gibt es schwächen ist das
wirklich so ist das dann auch ein
gewisses risiko was für ein antigen
schnell test man in der hand hat das ist
korrekt wir sind da schon auch vielfach
angefragt worden
ich muss gestehen wir haben auch nicht
die übersicht über diese vielfalt der
antigen schnell testsysteme
wir haben bei uns im labor bisher fünf
nur ausgetestet das war schon sehr sehr
viel arbeit und wir sehen bereits bei
diesen ersten fünf getesteten dass es da
unterschiede zwischen den testen gibt
manche sind etwas sensitiver andere sind
weniger sensitive sind dafür etwas
spezifischer dass da gibt es wirklich
große unterschiede
jetzt kommen ganz konkrete fragen silvia
schütz schreibt gibt es eine möglichkeit
an schnelltests für pflegebedürftige und
angehörige zu kommen die zu hause
versorgt werden also auch eine wichtige
sache oft ist ja in der tat die rede
immer von den pflegebedürftigen in
pflegeheimen sind ja spricht eben von
den pflegebedürftigen die zu hause sind
und die angehörigen die sie betreuen
damit weihnachten mit der familie
stattfinden kann ja das ist eine
wichtige frage die sie ansprechen und
bei uns soweit ich weiß sind diese
testsysteme noch nicht in der apotheke
frei verkäuflich das ist meine ich schon
in anderen ländern der fall
wichtig finde ich dass diese testsysteme
nicht einfach über die ladentheke
gereicht werden und die patienten damit
oder die personen damit allein gelassen
werden sondern ich finde es wichtig dass
wenn testsysteme in der apotheke
verkauft werden dort auch die testungen
gemacht werden
das personal geschult ist und dass man
nicht mit den puffern zu hause allein
gelassen wird und dann möglicherweise
fehler gemacht werden und dann ergebnis
rauskommen die dann alle nur verwirrung
also genau was sie sozusagen anschneiden
das ist so in der schweiz werden die
tests in der apotheke durchgeführt also
man kann in die apotheke gehen dann ist
es der apotheker der dort den test macht
150 apotheken in der schweiz bieten
diesen service an in frankreich gibt es
das ähnlich testung in den apotheken für
asymptomatische personen und bei
leichten fällen seit anfang november ist
das möglich die kosten werden sogar von
der staatlichen krankenkasse übernommen
aber auch dort ist es dann eben doch das
medizinische fachpersonal was das
letzten endes macht jetzt wäre die frage
wie sieht es denn mit hausärzten aus
wäre das eine möglichkeit kann ich zum
hausarzt hingehen und sagen hier bitte
nicht der pcr test aber ein antigen ein
schnelltest wäre das möglich ich denke
für regionen wo pcr auch nicht so
unmittelbar verfügbar ist zum beispiel
ländlichen regionen wo ihm einen
pcr-test zuerst einmal an ein labor
geschickt werden muss das dauert
teilweise mehrere tage da sind antigen
schnell testsysteme durchaus eine
alternative um einfach zeitnah ein
ergebnis zu haben
wenn es dann eben der hausarzt wenn es
wenigstens in ländlichen gebieten dann
den hausarzt um die ecke gibt über
youtube kommt auch noch eine
interessante frage von pinnacle it das
was ist das mindestalter um einen test
machen zu können kann man es denn auch
mit babys machen ab welchem alter gut
mit babys habe ich jetzt nicht so
erfahrung aber was wir bei kindern
machen und wir haben auch schon
kindergärten gescreent da geben wir
solche köpfchen aus dass die kinder
nicht diesen unangenehmen nasen
rachenabstrich durchführen müssen
sondern die kinder spielen den monte
oder gurgeln im mont und dann kann
dieses gurgel wasser eben auch für die
pcr genutzt werden aber für die antigen
schnell teste geht das nicht da braucht
man tatsächlich abstriche dann haben wir
insgesamt jetzt bereits begriffen dass
das mit den antigen schnelltests das
wort schnell suggeriert ja ein bisschen
alles kein problem aber doch nicht so
einfach ist wir haben es einzugehen
gesagt ab heute neu in deutschland die
verordnung des gesundheitsministers die
es ermöglicht mit dem neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz das eben auch
schon
lin und kitas schnelltests machen können
dass eben erzieher und lehrer sich
selbst testen können wenn sie eine
schulung gemacht haben und das schauen
wir uns mal an wie denn die schulen
reagiert haben ein beispiel dafür dass
man ein bisschen große fragezeichen
heute morgen über dem eingangstor an der
schule hatte ein beispiel
seit heute ist die neue corona
verordnung in kraft doch an den meisten
schulen in deutschland sieht es so aus
wie an der leonore goldschmidt schule in
hannover die schnelltests für lehrkräfte
gibt es schlicht noch nicht ich habe das
gestern auch aus der presse erfahren
und heute morgen in der zeitung gelesen
wenn das über den schulträger
angeschafft wird wird man sehen wie
lange das dauert erzieherinnen in
schulen und kitas dürfen die
schnelltests seit heute auch selber
durchführen nach einer schulung wären
die tests am ende bezahlt und ob
lehrkräfte auch schüler testen sollen
unklar
erzieher verbände sprechen von einem
schnellschuss der
bundesgesundheitsminister hält dagegen
ich habe nicht gesagt alle müssen jetzt
das sofort umsetzen ab heute sondern es
gab aus den bundesländern den wunsch und
wir haben es damit möglich gemacht
bislang sind 636 krone ausbrüche in
schulen bekannt in den vergangenen vier
wochen waren es 64 ausbrüche pro woche
tendenz steigend
ärzte warnen dennoch vor schnelltest
durch medizinische laien mein erster
gedanke war anschließend haben wir
lauter falsch negative tests und die
menschen wegen sich in der trügerischen
sicherheit und hinter haben wir mehr
infiziert als vorher
vor weihnachten wird es an den meisten
schulen aber wohl noch keine
schnelltests geben
bis dahin gilt weiter die hygieneregeln
beachten
[Musik]
was sagen sie denn zu der idee dass
jetzt lehrer und erzieher dass an der
schule selber machen können nach einer
klaren blitz schulung gesehen ich muss
ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen das kann ich
mir nicht vorstellen weil es sie müssen
hygiene richtlinien einhalten allein
wenn diese abstriche bei den schülern
entnommen werden da muss sich ja jemand
in schutzkleidung einholen und diese
abstriche auch korrekt durchführen und
dann die tests durchführen
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
lehrer schnell geschult werden und es
dann nach wenigen minuten alles
beherrschen also
unterstreichen sie ein bisschen das
fragezeichen was da in dem beitrag auch
der rektor hatte der sagt ich bin mir da
noch nicht so ganz sicher ja wir haben
darüber gesprochen was die gründe für
gewisse bedenken sind bei dieser
neuerung ab heute nämlich der umgang mit
diesem schnelltest die sicherheit und
daneben auch das risiko dass man sich
vielleicht in einer trügerischen
sicherheit wähnt die die grundsätzliche
idee des antigen schnell das ist ja eben
dass er etwas verbessert sozusagen ein
nachteil ausgleicht den der pcr test
über den sie ja schon gesprochen haben
hat nämlich dass es doch ein bisschen
länger dauert
reden wir drüber schauen uns aber erst
einmal ganz grundsätzlich an wie der pcr
test abläuft die gängigste art des
corona virus nachzuweisen ist der
sogenannte pcr test nach dem abt strich
geht die probe in ein labor dort wird
mit hilfe einer
polymerase-kettenreaktion also kurz pcr
untersucht ob das corona virus in der
probe enthalten ist
dafür wird das erbmaterial von wir und
so stark vervielfacht bis es
nachgewiesen werden kann
der pcr test ist gut der probe experten
schätzen seine zuverlässigkeit auf
nahezu 100 prozent sicherheitslücken
können aber entstehen etwa bei nicht
richtig durchgeführten abstrichen oder
wenn es probleme bei lagerung oder
transport gibt die analyse der probe
dauert etwa vier bis fünf stunden
nach entnahme der proben kann das ein
bis zwei tage dauern bis getestete ihr
ergebnis bekommen je nach proben
aufkommen kann sich die wartezeit auch
verlängern der pcr test gilt als bislang
zuverlässigstes corona testverfahren
frau professor löffler sehen sie das
auch so ist der pcr tests das
zuverlässigste verfahren absolut richtig
also der pcr test ist zur bewältigung
der korona krise tatsächlich unser gold
standard also kein test führen wir so
häufig durch wie die pcr test um
wir führen am tag allein für unser
krankenhaus hier und für umliegende
häuser über 700 teste durch um den
betrieb aufrecht zu erhalten
ja jetzt gibt es allerdings auch
menschen die einige zweifel haben
kritiker die die aussagekraft des pcr
tests an zweifeln über youtube
beschreibt hans ronald nitschke der pcr
test kann keine infektion nachweisen so
steht es in der gebrauchsanweisung
schreibt er
eine infektion kann nur ein arzt
feststellen wichtig ist der ct wert und
dieser wird nicht bewertet diese frage
oder dieses fragezeichen haben sozusagen
viele user uns zugeschickt
das ist richtig diese frage hatte ich
auch schon oft bekommen kurz zu diesen
ct wird der ct wert der gibt dir die
virus menge in der probe an also sprich
wenn der ct waz niedrig ist dann
bedeutet dass der patient hat eine sehr
sehr hohe virus last im nasen rachen
raum und das ist für uns ein zeichen der
patient ist sehr infektiös wir geben
mittlerweile auf unseren befunden den ct
wert mit an damit die ärzte auf der
intensivstation oder in der notaufnahme
damit so ein bisschen abschätzen können
wie infektiös ist der patient aber da
stellt sich natürlich die frage was
macht man sie sagen die reichen den ct
wert mit roter paravicini schreibt wenn
man nun zum pcr test aber keinen ct wert
bekommt ist der test dann wertlos
nein in keinem fall die die hersteller
der pcr testungen geben eben auch an bis
zu welchen ct wird eine probe als
positiv gewertet werden muss und ab
welchen ct wird man sagt das ist jetzt
unspezifisch das gilt als negativ
also da gibt es auch richtlinien und
das wird nicht immer angegeben das ist
richtig aber eine positive pcr messung
ist sehr sehr zuverlässig bleiben wir
beim ct wert es gibt hier eine frage
bitte den ct wird noch mal erklären
schreibt dominik schweer
wie hoch ist der ct wird und welche
konsequenzen ergeben sich daraus ich
werde mal einfach die folie die sie
geschickt haben auf schlagen und dann
können sie das mal erklären ist es jetzt
so ein niedriger ct wert ist das gut
oder ist ein hoher ct wert schlecht wie
sieht das aus es müssen sie mir erklären
also ein niedriger ct wert bedeutet dass
man wenige zyklen in der pcr die probe
bearbeiten muss also wenige heitz zyklen
anwenden muss damit man ein signal
kriegt das ist sozusagen die erste grüne
kurve die nach oben geht und aus dieser
kurve kammer errechnen oder runden
ablesen ab wieviel zyklen diese steigung
eben stattfindet und dass der cd wird
sehr niedrig ist bedeutet immer der
mensch bei dem diese probe entnommen
worden ist hat eine sehr sehr hohe virus
last also ein niedriger ct wert ist
sozusagen hochinfektiös
sie sehen wir kommen weitere kurven nach
oben und manche kurven die steigen erst
bei ct werten über 30 an
das sind eben proben wo eine sehr
niedrige viruslast beim patienten
vorliegt und dieser patient ist sicher
nicht so infektiös hat aber auch noch
vermehrungsfähige viruspartikel in
seinen nasen rachen raum hat das denn
jetzt folgen für die quarantäne dass der
ct wird dann genommen wird um zu sagen
du musst so lange in quarantäne du musst
so lange in quarantäne und du da ist das
so gering
du kannst ruhig raus in die
öffentlichkeit nein für die quarantäne
hätte das wurde noch nicht umgesetzt
allerdings hat es robert koch institut
schon ein anhalt rausgegeben und hat
gesagt ab einen ct wird von 30 ist ein
mensch wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
infektiös aber
wir lassen die leute tatsächlich noch im
krankenhaus als bevor wir sie aus diesem
comic bereich haus isolieren müssen drei
tatsächlich möglich negative abstriche
genommen sein so christel 1969 schreibt
der ct wert gibt nicht die viruslast an
sondern die anzahl der zyklen warum wird
das hier falsch erklärt das wort zyklen
habe ich ja aus ihrem mund gerade gehört
können sie das noch mal erklären
der ct werth ist tatsächlich die zyklus
zahl die in tampere notwendig gewesen
ist dass man eben ein positives signal
in der pcr maschine die diktieren kann
also sprich die zyklus zahl weil was
anders haben wir nicht die rna wird
vervielfältigt und wenn eben genug rna
markiert ist vervielfältigt worden ist
dann können wir das in der maschine
messen also letztendlich ist es richtig
ist dass die zyklus zahl aber die ist
proportional zur virus menge oder rna
menge so wir zeigen einfach mal ganz
kurz die grafik sie sich
freundlicherweise uns ja geschickt haben
und ich bitte dann um vergebung wenn das
hier klein ist und ich hätte man
vielleicht hier auf 150 prozent gehen
soll
aber hier unten ist es deutlich erklärt
da steht der ct wert anzahl der zyklen
bei denen die kurve in einen anstieg
über geht also haben wir das mal sauber
erklärt so wir haben aber noch mehr
fragen und zwar eine war habe ich schon
gesehen bis zu welchem ct wert wird in
deutschland getestet das ist auch je
nach pcr gerät wir machen das so dass
wir uns alle anstiege anschauen also
auch die bei die bei einer sehr hohen
zyklus zahl noch entstehen
und wenn diese anstiege sehr schön sind
und eben auf eine gute kurve hindeuten
dann wird dieses ergebnis noch mal
wiederholt auch wenn es bei einer sehr
hohen ct zahl war und ab einer ct
wertzahl von ich sag jetzt mal circa 35
37 da ist irgendwo der
dort wo man sagt hier diese cd werte
gehen jetzt das ist ein unspezifischer
anstieg und das sind die das sieht man
den kurven eigentlich in der regel an
wenn die nicht richtig positiv werden
also viele leute beschäftigen sich ja
und haben fragen zu den tc rcs heißt
positiv auch gleichzeitig ansteckend
eine gute frage
die schufa bern schreibt ja das konnten
es konnte man experimentell nie
eindeutig klären
also wir führen auch an zuchten von
virus durch in der zellkultur unsere
erfahrungen sind dass man infektions
also infektiöse partikel bis zu einem ct
wert von ca 30 noch an züchten kann
danach wird es wirklich schwierig und
das ist wahrscheinlich auch die basis
dieses robert-koch-institut eben
zugrunde legt wenn die aussage getätigt
wird ab 1 ct wert von 30 ist ein mensch
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr infektiös
wir haben eben auch kritische fragen
über youtube schreibt david macht es
sinn tests einzusetzen wo selbst der
erfinder sagt dass diese methode nicht
so diagnostischen zwecken geeignet ist
er meint vermutlich christian drosten
können wir jetzt nicht beantworten aber
wie sieht ihre antwort auf die frage aus
naja virus diagnostik ist schwieriger
als bakterien diagnostik bakterien kann
man einfach auf acker platten an züchten
und da hat mal wirklich die pathogene
direkt nachgewiesen die die krankheit
auslösen virus anzucht ist sehr
aufwändig werden kann man nur in
zellkulturen an züchten und das dauert
mehrere tage
und braucht unendlich viel eben labore
hochsicherheitslabor also eine
wahnsinnige ausstattung
wir haben schlichtweg einfach keine
andere zuverlässige methode als die rna
der wiehre nachzuweisen um das
diagnostisch zu verwenden
jetzt fragt eine ganz ich habe es noch
nicht gehört muss ich sagen sie sagen
gerade ob es damit etwas zu tun hat bei
youtube fragt galli 84 was ist ein rt
pcr
erlaubt ein rt pcr test eine aussage zu
zur infektion oder krankheit wofür steht
dieses rtt steht für real time pcr also
dann wird die die pci die pcr vielfältig
die ja die rna und es wird ein farbstoff
eingebaut in diese rna und die kann nach
einer bestimmten zyklus zahl eben dann
über diesen farbstoff gemessen werden
das sind diese kurven die zustande
kommen die dann die diktiert werden das
ist letztendlich eine real time pcr also
rt haben wir jetzt das geheimnis gelöst
riedlberger schreibt über youtube könnt
ihr dann bitte erklären wie die leute
darauf kommen dass die pcr tests erst
die pandemie erzeugt hätten das höre ich
häufig und verstehen nicht mal die logik
dahinter
das ist eine sache die schon mehrere
user hier über youtube geschrieben haben
keine pcr tests keine pandemie kann man
das so stehen lassen
na ja ich sag mal wir haben jetzt dieses
mittel der pcr um viren nachzuweisen
wenn sie 100 jahre zurückgehen in die
spanische grippe die von 1918 bis 20
auch in der ganzen welt eben gewütet hat
damals kannte man hier noch keine werden
damals hatte man ja keine pca testungen
damals vermutete man nur infektiöse
partikel die eben diese diese
schreckliche infektion weiter tragen
aber damals sind ganz viele leute
gestorben und es war wahnsinnig
aufwendig oder oder man hatte ganz wenig
an der hand diese infektion eben
einzudämmen und heute können wir
wenigstens testen ich denke das sind wir
großen schritt voraus
jetzt müssen sie als jemand die viel
teste die sich damit auskennt einem
krankenhaus im klinikum arbeitet können
mit sicherheit diese frage beantworten
die über facebook in die groß
geschrieben hat schadet das testen den
menschen dass das unangenehm ist haben
schon viele berichtet das ist klar aber
sie sagt ich meine dass einige menschen
nach dem testen kopfschmerzen bemerkten
ist das so oder ist das ein problem
ja wir haben auch schon gehört dass die
die korrekte durchführung dieses maßen
rachenabstrich dass es nicht angenehm
weil das stäbchen muss entweder durch
die nase oder durch den rachen wirklich
tief eben bis zur drachen hinterwand
geführt werden das ist sicher nicht
angenehm und ich kann mir schon
vorstellen dass man dann auch kopfweh
oder schmerzen an den schleimhäuten hat
wie gesagt für kinder ist das natürlich
auch nicht angenehm aber trotzdem durch
dieses viele testen konnten wir zum
beispiel verhindern dass im krankenhaus
patienten infiziert werden dass wir
erleben wir wissen durch diese vielen
testungen wie sich die infektion
ausbreitet und können natürlich nur
dadurch infektionsketten auch aufdecken
und daneben auch durchbrechen
ich meine heute muss man sich noch mal
die zahlen vor augen halten die das lka
gemeldet hat dann sind es nichts zu
rütteln gibt 23 1449 neuinfektionen
wenn das alles glimpflich ablaufen würde
wäre es ja schön und gut wenn das nur
mit kopfschmerzen zu tun hätte aber 432
menschen sind in nur 24 stunden in
zusammenhang mit 19 gestorben dann muss
jeder vielleicht sich selbst da
überlegen wie die prioritäten zu setzen
sind kann man ausschließen fragte im
thaler über facebook dass dieser pcr
test auch bei anderen viren ein
positives ergebnis liefert zum beispiel
bei grippeviren schnupfenviren herpes
viren etc
also hier werden kreuzreaktionen
angesprochen aber die pcr sonden sind
doch sehr spezifisch auf die saas kopf 2
virus und das haben wir auch getestet
das wissen wir
das sind spezifische gene elemente die
den virus eigensinn und die zum beispiel
die anderen coronaviren die wir ja auch
saisonal haben oder die grippeviren
nicht haben und die dik diktieren wir
mit dieser methode nicht gleich im
anschluss die frage nicht springen die
tests auch auf alte corona viren an
haben sie gerade erwähnt
das ist das genau das haben wir auch
getestet und natürlich die wir haben
auch saisonale coronaviren die bis bei
uns bisher keine rolle gespielt haben
es immer noch nicht tun die detektieren
wir mit dieser pcr mit diesen
spezifischen sonden nicht also hier
besteht keine kreuzreaktion auch noch
mal so eine kritische frage über youtube
wie ist das denn mit dem gerücht dass
wiederholte pcr test bei gesunden
menschen positive ergebnisse erzeugen
warum stimmt das nicht und wie kommen
die leute darauf fragt er
das weiß ich auch nicht wie die leute
darauf kommen also es heißt nicht ich
teste ich zehnmal an irgendwann werde
ich positiv dass er habe ich auch noch
nicht erlebt muss ich ehrlich sagen hans
eppler jens eppler schreibt ist denn
schon klar ob ein falsch negativ
getestete ansteckend ist er könnte ja
noch nicht ansteckend sein aber das ist
natürlich eine schwierige frage das
feuer zu sehen
das ist richtig in der ganz frühen phase
der infektion ist es möglich dass man
eben noch nicht ansteckend ist also man
braucht schon eine gewissen virus last
im nasen-rachen-raum bis man eben mit
ein abstrich und mit pcr dann die viren
auch detektieren kann das kann einige
tage dauern
nach der ansteckung und auch im
krankheitsfalle auf also wenn jemand
stark an krone also eine cupid infektion
ausbildet haben wir auch schon den fall
gehabt dass patienten gar nicht mehr so
hohe virus lasten im nasen-rachen-raum
haben aber die viren mehr in die lunge
wandern und dort diese person eben sehr
krank machen also konkrete antworten es
gibt aber immer das beobachten wir alle
leute die eben sagen ach corona gibt es
doch gar nicht
es ist eine verschwindende minderheit
die aber doch ziemlich lautes und
protestiert jetzt muss ich sie einfach
mal direkt fragen was sagen sie denn
oder welches bild ich habe meine folie
vorgelegt die sie geschickt haben würden
sie denn diesen leuten zeigen die sagen
es gibt überhaupt nicht corona es ist
alles erfunden das ist alles propaganda
na ja wir haben ja auch schlimme corona
fälle auch wenn wir nicht so viele fälle
haben wir beispielsweise in frankreich
oder italien
wir haben auch sehr schwer und krone
erkrankte patienten bei uns auf den
intensivstationen liegen
und das sind nicht nur ganz alte
patientin sondern teilweise eben auch
patienten in jüngeren jahren also das
kann jeden betreffen und das problem
jetzt völlig runter zu spielen nur weil
man selbst nicht betroffen ist das ist
natürlich schon sehr gewagt ja ich habe
die frage sozusagen jetzt ihnen gestellt
weil wir die hier vielleicht in einem
nachrichtenstudio im zdf sind die
draußen auf der straße sind ja nicht
sozusagen das corona virus sehen das ist
ja auch eine ganz schwierige sache wenn
man etwas nicht sieht es ist ja eine
unsichtbare gefahr irgendwie aber ich
frage sie jetzt absichtlich ganz lieb
weil sie ja jemand sind die durch das
labor mikroskop guckt und sozusagen dem
virus kann man fast sagen in die augen
schaut erklären sie einfach mal ganz
kurz was ihr da auf den fotos sehen was
sie sozusagen mit ihren augen doch
tatsächlich eben durchs mikroskop sie
richtige also für alle die meinen corona
ist nun pcr phänomen also wir können
diese viren tatsächlichen der zellkultur
an züchten und da werden eben virus
material oder material von diesen
rachenabstriche von patienten wird auf
solche zellkulturen gegeben die sie hier
am rande in diesem schälchen sehen und
wenn die viren dort mindestens einen tag
gelebt haben oder mehrere tage gezüchtet
worden sind dann kann man den zellen
ansehen das ist jetzt die untere
abbildung ja das ist in zellen wirklich
nicht mehr so gut geht die geht die
kugeln sich abdi werden rund die lösen
sich von ihren platten und wenn man die
oberfläche dieser infizierten zellen
dann mit einem elektronenmikroskop
anschaut und das sieht mein ding und
werden dieses hier sehen sie diese diese
titel länder auf der zelloberfläche und
das sind die viren die von den
wirtszellen produziert werden also
ausgeschleust werden und dann massiv in
die umgebung freigesetzt werden dass er
schon sehr erschreckend wenn man das
sieht das so sterben der zellen dann so
viele viren noch freigeben können
ja und man muss sich dann mit anderen
leuten mit ärzten unterhalten die auf
intensivstationen arbeiten
mein schwager ist arzt in einem
krankenhaus in istanbul mit 170 cupid 19
patienten in der spitze und der dann
sagt wenn man jeden tag drei leichen hat
drei sterbende drei tote
dann weiß man dass die sache ernst zu
nehmen ist das ist einfach mal dann
sozusagen sie gucken durchs mikroskop
und sagen ja es gibt corona es gibt
dieses virus und die ärzte die auf den
intensivstationen die menschen behandeln
oder dann am ende nicht mehr helfen
können die können sozusagen durch ihre
augen das ganze sehen wir bedanken uns
ganz ganz ganz herzlich dafür dass sie
die ganzen fragen beantwortet haben eine
ganze ganze menge erklärt haben ich habe
auch der ganze menge jetzt dazu gelernt
wir sagen vielen vielen dank weiterhin
guter arbeit und sagen liebe grüße nach
jener vielen dank frau professor lösung
ja vielen dank ja das war unser zdf
heute live mit ihren fragen mit
antworten die ihnen hoffentlich auch
weitergeholfen haben mit interessanten
erklärungen und filmen zum thema wie was
wie zuverlässig sind die tests was
bewirken sie wie funktionieren sie was
sind die vor und nachteile
ganz herzlichen dank für ihr interesse
bis bald tschüss und auf wiedersehen